good morning Hank it's Tuesday and your
video last week you mentioned this New
Yorker profile of Partners in Health
co-founder affiliate all and ever since
reading it I've been thinking about
Ebola remember Ebola an outbreak of the
virus in 2014 killed over 10,000 people
and to quote some 2014 headlines Ebola
was a global health crisis of pandemic
and above all and emergency and I think
in general humans are quite good at
responding to emergencies we rally
together in the immediate wake of
disasters we raise money we Lobby our
governments but we really struggle when
it comes to long-term solutions to
long-term problems back in 2014 the
world responded to the Ebola emergency
with big health care investments in the
nation's affected by the outbreak Guinea
Sierra Leone and Liberia and then to
quote The New Yorker article as soon as
Ebola appeared to be stabilized the
money evaporated the influx of aid in
2014 did help end the Ebola crisis but
it did very little to address the
long-term crisis like when the outbreak
began Sierra Leone a nation of over
seven million people had fewer than 200
doctors and over five percent of them
died of Ebola in 2014 for context my
home state of Indiana which has a
slightly smaller population than Sierra
Leone has over 16,000 practicing
physicians short-term aid did not fix
that problem Sierra Leone still has far
too few health workers who are paid far
too little and facilities are hugely
inadequate more than half of the public
hospitals in Sierra Leone lack running
water and drugs and other supplies are
often out of stock and all of that has
real catastrophic consequences 9 percent
of kids born in Sierra Leone will die
before they're five and I want to say
here that I'm totally unconvinced by the
argument that these problems are not our
problems or that the inadequacies of
Sierra Leone's health care system should
be fixed entirely within Sierra Leone I
just think that ignores so much
complexity and also so much history the
history of slavery and colonialism but
also much more recently that Sierra
Leone was forced for decades to spend
less than five dollars per person per
year on health care by misguided global
loan regulations and we also can't
ignore how deeply interconnected and
interdependent we are as a species like
when inadequate stocks of drugs and lack
of health care facilities mean that
people's tuberculosis treatment gets
interrupted the multi drug-resistant
tuberculosis that spreads is not only a
problem for Sierra Leone as Ophelia Dahl
put it a bola was acute on chronic
that's what they call it when someone
has smokers long
and then suddenly something precipitous
happens like pneumonia as long as the
world fails to meet basic health care
needs we will continue to experience
acute on chronic emergencies in fact in
Sierra Leone in 2014
twice as many people died of
tuberculosis as died of Ebola and almost
all of those TB deaths were preventable
but training and paying more health care
workers improving facilities spending
money on ongoing restocking of drugs all
of these require long-term investments
these are changes we chart over years
and decades not over days and weeks but
we can see changes like life expectancy
in Sierra Leone is low but it's rising
the health care system is woefully
underfunded but it is nonetheless better
than it was 10 or 20 or 50 years ago now
none of this is to say that we should
stop responding to emergencies like
let's definitely stay good at that or
even try to get better at it to me this
is not an either/or proposition it's a
both/and proposition let's both respond
to emergencies and try to focus more
attention and resources on long-term
problems and the long-term solutions
they demand there's a link below to that
article about Ophelia Dahl and Partners
in Health it really is fascinating by
the way for those who don't know
nerdfighteria has donated more than a
million dollars in total over the last
several years to partners and health I
think it's helpful to understand how far
that money has gone but also how far we
still have to go frankly it's
infuriating to think about the hospitals
that have had to close since the Ebola
money dried up and the lives that have
ended as a result I guess we can only
hope that these outrages and all
outrages spark empathy and commitment
instead of fear and resignation Hank
I'll see you on Friday